herzlich willkommen
die kleinen zuckersüßen stücke
bewusstsein verliert auf
[Musik]
das geht hier um styling 2020 ach das
ist ja meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal an alle die es
nicht mitbekommen haben gestern war das
heck topmodel 2020 finale
ich zum beispiel habe es nicht
mitbekommen von daher hab ich mir
gedacht ja gestern war das kind em
finale dann reagieren wir doch jetzt
einfach mal zusammen das umstyling das
hat vor allen dingen wochen
stattgefunden allerdings reagierte er
jedes jahr drauf und dieser habe ich es
einfach vergessen
man habe ich angefangen mit der bianca
das weiß ich natürlich weil ich sie
kennt und nicht weil hinter der fels
camille nahm eingeblendet sind sie
bianca sauer vorher so aus nachher sah
sie da
die sieht aus wie eine punk sängerin aus
den 80ern machen wir allerdings direkt
weiter mit der nächsten person und zwar
es ist diana stars
da
also das ist auf jeden fall die
schielende anders
der hier vorher sieht so aus ist ein
relativ normaler style würde ich sagen
mit den haaren nachher sei warum wissen
die denn immer gefühlt in alufolie
einwickeln
damit ihnen nicht krank werden immer
schön warm bleiben in diesen tagen wo es
gerade ja auch nur 30 grad draußen sind
was sind das lockt damit scheint auch
wieder eine animation wo wir uns direkt
anschauen können okay luc 1 hätte so
ausgesehen look 2 hätte so ausgesehen
und produkt 3 hätte so ausgesehen das
sieht dann schon eher aus dem hexenbesen
aber die haben sich dann schlussendlich
für keinen der luchs entschieden sondern
für den hier poster an der saar oder ist
es dass hier der comteam aber schon am
nächsten aber egal gut komme
ich habe auch schon kassandra sage ich
ja immer kessy sage ich immer dass eine
gute freundin von mir mal auf nachher
kess dieser nachher so aus das
schachbrettmuster tlug 1 2 unserer
lieben cathy hätte so ausgesehen ein
gott das ist ein ganz anderer mensch
das ist ein ganz anderer mensch okay luc
2 hätte soll das ist auch ein ganz
anderer mensch und luk 3
das an dann guckt euch das an oder guckt
euch das an das sind für mich kessy
kassandra und cassidy nah aber nach
meiner allerliebsten freundin cassie
kommen jetzt an jacqueline ich sage er
war jackie das war sie auf jeden fall
vorher susan lee jackie auf jeden fall
deutlich besser aus einem block 1 bei
der jackie sah so aus so kann ich mir
auch gut vorstellen look 2.2 kann ich
mir bei keinem irgendwie vorstellen
luck 33 fühle ich auch nicht so sehr
aber gut nach der liebe jack die commerz
johanna wir sind alle so wirklich johnny
und ich kenne sie ja ich sage mal wir
sind eine große familie johanna sei auf
jeden fall vorher so außen nachher sagt
sie so dass fast nichts verändert ihre
haare ein bisschen geglättet aber gut
look 1a bei der johanna oder johnny seit
januar so ausflug zwei so lockt drei so
also er dafür nicht haben sie es haben
sie gar nichts gemacht nichts gegen dich
johnny wir trinken nachher wieder ein
café nächste personen ist auf jeden fall
die julia saner juli wegen dem juli
so hat sich auf jeden fall vorher aus
ich weiß nicht was man bei den haaren
verändern sollte
sie hat halt keine nachher sagen sie
dann auf jeden fall hat sie eine perücke
aufgesetzt bekommen oder wie aber wenn
man immer den look anguckt nähe finde
ich passt nicht passt auch nicht finde
ich doch das wird noch am ehesten passt
findet das passt schon
ich find glatze passt zu ihr juli wir
sehen uns auf jeden fall auch die tage
auf den kleinen t hier neben einem café
am ohr julia mit der mich nicht so viel
mehr zu tun die war ein bisschen so dann
haben wir auseinander julia sei auf
jeden fall vorher so außen nachher sah
die julia so aus okay
julia ich habe damals geklickt
für julia und c in style präsentieren
mal in rot die simulation redet mit mir
mein einziger freund ich weg mit ein
bisschen betrunken finde ich oder
naja manchmal weiter mit dem nächsten
personen zwar ist
ich kenne übrigens keinen von denen ich
das hier wieder irgendjemand denkt hier
acht kommen ich hier jetzt luca mit den
allen soll ja vorgekommen sein mit
seiner französischen frau hat mir
übrigens nicht noch mal geschrieben
falls jemand fragt er ist das auf jeden
fall vorher so aus nachher samariter so
aus ich finds vorher viel besser das
finde ich das passt gar nicht jetzt ein
schelmisches grinsen bisschen ich finde
das passt mehr zusammen etwas locker
acht nicht blockieren aber etwas
offeneren ist hat mich ob ich habe keine
ahnung ich habe keine ahnung wie sie
trug 1/2 jahr geht noch lockt 380 geht
auch ne so würde ich dann aber tragen
doch ich finde so salehi auf jeden fall
am besten aus die begrüße jeden fall
erwarten wir weiter mit den linien liana
ach gottchen habe ich immer probleme den
namen auszusprechen
diana war vorher so außen nachher haben
sie so viel besser finde ich viel besser
ich finde ich bin die liane ein bisschen
so zurückhaltend da hier das grinsen
look 1 auf jeden fall bei ihr so aus
auch finde ich look zwei vielleicht mit
stromer in gott
das passt am besten
ja eigentlich gesagt zwei passende man
will ja ich sag ja alle krank krank
übrigens die eltern von liliana haben
sie früher nur jana getauft da sie
allerdings nie wirklich groß wurde haben
sie diesen liliana getauft war schlecht
liliana ist übrigens die tochter von
lucy ist hier die nächste die kenne ich
tatsächlich mal nicht soll ja auch
vorkommen dass auf jeden fall vorher so
aus wie ein ganz normaler sie ist ja
fast so wie der hintergrund lucy es gibt
also was das nennt sich sonne hält wie
gesagt wenn ich betrunken mein gott also
keine kommentare von mir sind um gottes
willen würde gemeint ich glaube das
wissen mittlerweile nachher sei die lucy
so ein ganz anderer mensch sie bisschen
aus wie heidi klum die voll aus wie
heidi klum aber gut springen von der
lose direkt weiter mit mareike
wenn ich mich im spiegel sehen würde
fühlt ich denke ich kann mich eine tonne
kloppen heute war es auf jeden fall
vorher so aus mit den geflochtenen
haaren hier am rand nachher sieht sie
salam aleikum heißt salam aleikum und
ich das macht auch gar kein sonderlich
dass gott gesagt habe aber ich finde es
passt zu ihr ich finde es passt vor
allem mit den tattoos und so dass mit
dem gerade steht ihr gut
ich sage ja mal grau steht gut und tut
selten gut
fragt mich
ich hab nichts getrunken
hätte ich schon
keinen tropfen alkohol getrunken warum
bin ich youtube erste person ist auf
jeden fall marie belsen ganz normales
mädchen würde ich sagen hier auf einen
sehr unscheinbar endlich ihr wisst was
ich meine
nachher auch wieder hier so ein bisschen
sieht sondern so ein bisschen aus wie
diese schwarzen blackberry mich auch
reicht jetzt auch keins aber in der
marienberger passt ja überhaupt nicht
luck zwei finde ich auch gar nicht club
drei noch am ehesten das haben sie gut
hingekriegt maribel ja wir lieben dich
schreit kommentiert mal ein herz kommen
film maribel man was sonst perfekte herz
gailbach nach der maribel verstehe die
ganze zeit so ja wahrscheinlich haben
sie es gar nicht die ganze zeit
naja erreicht jetzt aufmerksam machen
wir weiter mit marie
gott mache weiter mit maurice maurer
komm wir machen das ganze jetzt hier
ohne face kann weiter ich glaube das
macht am meisten sinn bevor ich noch
weiter schwach was ist das denn sie auf
spongebob beziehen
mit den haaren kommunen look pass gar
nicht herr kummer wenn ich das tragen
würde
ich habe jetzt haben erst einmal wieder
in festem gut lukas kam aus und dann
direkt hier natürlich nicht mit langen
haaren vorstellen nein das auf jeden
fall marines sind ich habe es auf jeden
fall auch besser hingekriegt
nadine adelsried vor so aus nachher so
in athen wird es bei der der look 1 bei
einer din sah so aussieht eigentlich
genauso außen relativ wenig erinnert ihn
ist eine süße dies eine süsse flugzeuge
noch gar nicht aber nachher haben sie
auf jeden fall gut hingekriegt bei der
lieben der dienstherr die wir sind ja
schon so sind wir so nach nadine kommen
wir zum final pina pina colada hier 1,3
muss er lachen oder weinen sitzt pina
colada auf jeden fall auch gut machen
wir weiter sarah punkt 12 sarah oder was
ich sehe keine veränderung ich sehe
absolut keine veränderung machen wir
weiter mit sarah s punkt ahadi haben wir
auch noch die kug bisschen böse konnte
ich keinen bock
ich will bei ihr gemahl look 1 euro da
sie zwar nicht happy darüber ausflug
zwei auch nicht so glücklich und block 3
gibt es ein bisschen so
damit sich die mich gut machen wir damit
war tamara tamara vorher so tamara
nachher so
er finde ich vorher viel besser ich
finde da passt dass sie auf jeden fall
besser als das hier machen allerdings
weiter mit der vision und das sollte die
letzte für heute
an der stelle mich das heutige wir jetzt
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen haben eine reaktion
hierauf next topmodel umstyling 2020 ich
weiß nicht wer ein paar monate zu spät
aber corona und so kam dazwischen und
ich hatte auch gar keine zeit jetzt ich
hab' ich habe doch gar nicht vergessen
wenn es euch gefallen hat dass keine
daumen hoch unser video da ich hoffe das
hat es getan wenn es das getan hat dann
abonniert doch gerne einen youtube-kanal
ich weiß dass sehr viele von euch kein
abonnent sind mensch und ich glaube ich
habe auch euch oder wenn es doch machen
wollt dann könnt ihr auch einfach hier
auf den smiley draufklicken denn dann
werdet ihr aber dann von meinem kanal
teil der luke schon ihr verpasst keine
videos mehr und hier ist ein video
verlinkt was neue von einem schweizer
kanal ist
ja kann ich euch auch nicht so ganz
empfehlen aber wir haben ja gerade alles
nichts zu tun
pauli